horror movies have been freaking out
audiences for over 100 years but it
turns out that once you take away the
spooky lighting ominous music and scary
masks a terrifying spectacle can easily
become nothing more than just a bunch of
people having fun here are some
amusingly disillusioning set photos that
will keep you from looking at iconic
horror movies the same way ever again
Freddy Krueger is easily the most
charismatic killer of the 80 / or era as
The Nightmare on Elm Street franchise
expanded Freddy became quippy ER and
paneer until he basically turned into
the 80s version of a slightly less
murdery Deadpool without a mask but
before he became such a cuddly figure he
was a serial killer with wizard powers
who was probably also a child abuser
that's why it's kind of jarring to see
him chilling with the teens he would
dream murder while bumping 1984 his
biggest hits at a Walkman not even a
living nightmare could resist taking a
break with Stevie Wonder's I just called
to say I love you by tearing away the
curtain of fantasy these
behind-the-scenes photos reminds you
that these monsters are just puppets or
people in makeup breaking the illusion
and removing most of the horror the
problem with this shot from behind the
scenes of 1990s gremlins 2 the new batch
is that it's actually way scarier than
anything in the movie this brainy
gremlin spider gremlin back from baby
electricity gremlin Hulk Hogan's don't
be innovation the adorable Mogwai gizmo
is arguably the hero and definitely the
breakout star of the gremlins franchise
so he's generally meant to be cute and
tiny rather than scary but makeup artist
Rick Baker's team built a prototype
human sized suit for a small actor to
fit into so gizmo could walk around on
camera thankfully this idea was ditched
and this horrifying presumably
child-eating suit never appeared on
camera
thirsty lady gremlin was scary enough
2006 is Pan's Labyrinth was arguably the
film that made director Guillermo del
Toro a household name the film uses dark
fantasy to create a dream world in which
the horrors of fascist Spain are
reflected by the horrors of a big maze
with monsters in it the monster who
gives his name to the title is the faun
but the real nightmare star is the pale
man whose eyeballs in the palms bit is
probably the film's most memorable
visual the actor behind the faun would
probably be mad that the pale man
upstaged him if it weren't for the fact
that they were played by the same actor
Doug Jones Jones is reportedly a very
nice person despite his monstrous roles
so it's no surprise to see him showing
some affection behind the scenes to his
makeup artist 1974 is the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre is one of the most influential
and beloved horror films ever made
1986 is Texas Chainsaw Massacre 2 has
something less of a critical consensus
behind it but his reputation has grown
in recent years director tobe Hooper
wanted the sequel to expand on the black
comedy elements of the first film so it
really ramps up the satire as well as
the gore to make it something almost as
over-the-top as the first film is
understated the spirit of the film
really shows in this behind-the-scenes
photo in which Leatherface is playing
cards with his brothers to cook and chop
top in a game that seems to have gone
somewhat awry but far less awry than
their usual games the Hellraiser
franchise is about demons from another
dimension and leather gear with
elaborate body mods that steal people's
souls easily the most recognizable
character is pinhead a leader of descent
abides portrayed in the first seven
films by Doug Bradley according to an
interview with birth movies death
promoting Hellraiser 3 in 1992 Bradley
was walking through New York and full
costume so that he could present a prop
to Planet Hollywood naturally his
presence drew quite a crowd and at some
point one of the dozens of people
following him down the street asked him
to take a picture holding a baby
Bradley refers to this as pinhead
running for president Wes Craven's and
Nightmare on Elm Street ended up
exploding into a massive franchise and
pretty much everyone agrees that out of
all the sequels the best one is part
three the dream warriors one of the most
important additions to the Elm Street
mythos in this film is the role of
Kristen Parker portrayed by Patricia
Arquette who has the ability to summon
other people into the dream world at
will and one of her most famous scenes
is the one in which Freddy appears as a
giant snake that tries to swallow
Kristen whole until he stabbed with a
shard of glass and pukes are up as cool
as that scene is it's somewhat undercut
by this shot of Arquette not at all
bothered to be halfway down Freddy's
gullet check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]